what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today we have
morning coffee thoughts but I don't have
coffee it's not the morning
this is tea yeah so maybe I should call
it Pearl's drinking a beverage and
giving her thoughts but both start don't
forget to like the video subscribe to
the channel and ring that notification
Bell
guys I feel like I have so much to tell
you I have a wild story that happened to
me
I have
some haters that I feel like I should
address
and I have a video that I've been
wanting to make about advice that my
parents gave me growing up so
today I decided to do option number
three I want to give you guys advice
that my parents gave me growing up that
really helped me in life um you guys can
take it or leave it and
stuff that helped me I feel on my way to
success so
I made oh gosh I almost dropped this
phone I made a list so the first being
my dad always told me to invest money in
coaching growing up I wanted to be a
volleyball player and I went from the
bottom team at my club so it was black
red white were the colors of teams and
white was the worst team and black was
the best team and I was on the worst
team now again at this point not
everyone can afford private lessons but
I always did extra lessons outside of
practice
and I was always asking people that know
more than me about volleyball and by my
senior year I was at benchwarmer on the
third team at my when I was 15 I was a
benchwarmer on the third team and by my
senior year I was starting on the first
team and my whole team won D1 I chose
not to but
you know and that's always what D1
people say but I I want D3 but it was
still a really big accomplishment for me
to move up the teams and I attribute
that to spending money on coaching
granted my parents did pay for it but
I took this mindset into business
and I would invest my own money with
coaching sessions and chasing down
people a lot of people if you ask for
career advice will just give it to you
for free I have given people such good
advice for their channels for absolutely
no money usually it's because I like
them or I know them or whatever but I do
charge if I don't know you but you know
there's people that have weaseld their
way in for a lot of free advice
or if I think they're talented sometimes
I'll just do it but anyways
um don't don't make that an invite for
random people my inboxes no I'm not
gonna do it
unless you butter me up in person but
that's a different day anyways so this
mindset I took into business
and a lot of people are afraid they
think oh well what if I waste money what
if the coaching is bad I don't want to
spend 200 300 405 whatever the money is
dollars I spent a thousand and that was
a risk at the time my dad told me that
was too much money but
the mindset is the same it's okay to
waste money on bad employees and bad
coaches in order to get to good coaches
and it's the same thing with Outsourcing
and hiring people I was very quick to
Outsource people like before I even I
paid people more money than I made for a
very long time actually last month was
the first month where I think I actually
made the most at my company take home
and I still might not because I I'm look
there's some equipment I want to buy I
don't know I get trigger happy okay my
producer has stuff he wants and I'm like
ah that would look good you know what I
mean and
because of that
a lot of people are afraid to spend
money on people what if you waste your
money now in business you are going to
waste money do not spend any money that
you need to make back don't because you
won't and at the first couple months
you're just gonna lose money
but it's worth it because
let's say I hire a bad employee or a bad
coach I know what to look for in the
next coach so I know what not to get and
then you get one person and one person
closer to getting a good coach because I
think of long term and when I thought of
my business long term I was like I don't
see myself getting that good at editing
I don't see myself getting that good at
thumbnails I'm not that passionate about
it I'm passionate about entertaining
people making entertaining content
and just doing a good show and bringing
men and women together I really like
matchmaking I really like families I
really like success stories so that's
what I'm passionate about and I was like
why would I spend the time
trying to get good at other things if I
could just get good at that okay second
thing
when I was a kid when I was in
I don't know how old I was I think I was
in Middle School
I felt like I was stupid and for a
really really long time this was
something that I was really really
insecure about
um the reason being I was a year young
in school so when I graduated high
school I was 17 and when I started
college I was 17 and
um when I went to pre-k or whatever I
was I was a year young and when you're a
year young you're actually it may not
seem like it you're like it's only a
year but when you're five
that's a fifth of your life and you're
you feel a lot younger than everyone
else and you're less mature than
everyone else it was the same thing in
first second third fourth fifth sixth
grade like the older I get the got the
less it mattered but I always felt like
because I was a year young I felt behind
and I felt stupid
and one day I was always really bad at
math
and I'm still bad at math and Excel to
this day my dad yells at me about it a
lot he always we look at our expenses
and he's like why would you do this
and then he's always like did you do
your expenses I'm like hell on Earth
anyways that's not the point the point
is this that
my dad I remember I still remember to
this day because I was crying in the car
and my dad went to the University of
Chicago my dad's a very smart guy he
tries to pretend it's how hard he works
and it is my dad's extremely hard worker
but he is also
just so intelligent like I could show
him any math problem in high school and
he would think it through and he could
teach it back to me later and me I don't
quite have that skill so so I was crying
and I was saying it's so easy for you
Dad you're so smart like you
everything's easy for you in life
because you're just the smartest and you
don't know what it's like to be stupid
and uh you know I was being a woman
crying and I'm around I got a little
emotional I got a flashback I I swear to
God it's funny I haven't been insecure
about this in a long time but this was
like one of my biggest insecurities
growing up and
he said he looks at me and he says
it is not about how hard you work or
sorry he looks at me says Hannah my
first name's Hannah he says Hannah it is
not about it is not about how smart you
are it's about how hard you work and you
are a hard worker and you can't teach
that and I hire people every day and I
will take a hard worker over a smart
person every day because you think about
it you do an extra two hours a day for a
week and you do that for 30 40 years the
older you get the less it matters how
smart you are the older you get your
life shows what you did the last 20 30
40 years and the winners come out from
the losers and I remember being like
whatever dad like I
but this conversation stuck out to me
and it stuck out to me because
he was right he was absolutely right
like the older I get I
I ended up getting better grades than a
lot of people that were smarter than me
I ended up making more money and being
more successful than a lot of people
that were smarter than me I went further
in sports than a lot of people that were
more athletic than me and I attribute it
to my work ethic and
I I truly believe that you can do
anything and I actually wish earlier in
life I had more confidence because
I didn't realize how powerful your work
ethic is like it is so powerful to the
point I I have a friend named Ali you
guys have seen on my channel and she
says you're the only [ __ ] that I know
manifests things and I don't really
manifest it I just have a goal and I
keep trying to like move towards the
goal and if there's an obstacle I just
keep trying to think of a way to like
fix it and that's the unique thing about
me I mean I don't want to say it's
Unique there's a lot of people that have
that but that's what sets people apart
and that's what set me apart in six
classes there was a million roadblocks
but I'm just always trying to think of a
solution and if there's one thing in my
life that nobody can say is that I'm
lazy they can call me dumb they could
say
they could say that maybe you know my
parents helped me they could say
whatever whatever but there's nobody
that knows me personally that will call
me lazy
um anyways third piece of advice
this is longer than I thought this video
was going to be but anyways third piece
of advice make good habits while you're
young
now this was a combination of my parents
and Jordan Peterson but your habits are
who you are and that's who you become so
I'm a different person than I was 10
years ago I mean I think there's core
like my dad will always say that people
their core is the same but your habits
make up who you are and I have a
relative who she was a genius and she
drank hers like I mean she's still alive
but she basically is drunk herself to
death and it's like that one decision
for her to drink
turned into a bunch of issues down the
road where people we don't even
recognize who she is anymore and it's
the same thing like I drank a lot
I don't say a lot but
because then the internet's like you're
an alcoholic you did all this stuff blah
blah blah but I did drink in college
right and when I graduated I wanted to
be sure that I that would never be
something I would be dependent on I
wasn't really close to it most people
would probably say you're fine but it
was to the point where I was like you
know what
I would rather
be safe than sorry so I like made sure I
cut back on that early in my life
because I was like you know what you all
have only drank for three years it'll be
easy to cut now if you do it for 10
years it's gonna be hard to cut and yeah
ever since then I really I maybe drank
like a couple times a year and if I did
it really wasn't anything crazy so
make the habits you make while you're
young are who you are and be careful
what habits you add into your life
because you just never know what the
ramifications of one small decision
could be
um fourth thing
the truth always comes out in the long
run so
there have been times where people
threatened to sue me for certain things
and with the show and or other whatever
whatever it is right and the thing is my
dad always said the truth comes out
eventually it does not hide forever
sooner or later someone talks someone
says something so don't ever be afraid
that someone is going to come for you
because the truth always comes out and
the truth will set you free so he always
said be honest tell the truth and in the
long run the truth will always come out
uh fifth piece of advice my parents gave
me don't get tattoos as a woman because
men look at that as trashy my mom told
me that from a young age and don't get
fat she said it's the easiest in your
life as a young woman to stay skinny and
if you get fat now later in life it's
going to be hard and that's the same
thing with with eating my eating has
gotten so much better the last couple
years and I attribute it to working
really hard at it because I mean I still
have a wisco I'm not perfect I have
issues but
it's the same thing it goes back to the
habits you make when you're young and
she just told me at 18 do you really
know what you want your body to look
like and she said all the tattoos look
like leather when you're older they
don't look good yeah she just told me
not to get tattoos and
I bought her on this I called her
judgmental
but the older I get the more I'm like
thank you Mom for not letting me get
that she said the same thing about
piercings she said those are trashy
heavy makeup trashy fake eyelashes
trashy and
she just said when you go out
you want to look classy you don't want
to show a lot of skin
uh my mom didn't like I'm sorry I'm
wearing the sweats again but she really
would not encourage me to wear sweats
and this is something I still have a
hard time with because when I'm going to
the gym I just don't care and sometimes
I'm just tired and I just don't care but
she said the way you dress depicts who
you are and when you go places
make sure you're dressed to impress
because you never know who you're going
to run into you always want to be
confident and you just always want to
like look like a piece of art kind of I
don't know
um okay six okay this
has really helped me on the internet
so my dad always told me
people's opinions don't matter people's
opinions don't matter how so whenever
someone would say something about me on
the internet I'd be like Dad this person
said this and this or I would say my
friend said this and this or I would say
someone else said this and this do you
know what I'm saying so like I would be
mad about someone's opinion and my dad
always told me
their opinions don't matter
he would say how many people most people
in life you don't deal with that long
you don't deal with them that long for
the like how even in college you'd be
like how long are you really going to
deal with your college friends maybe a
couple after college the only people the
only people's opinions that matter are
your families because the rest of the
world doesn't matter and so I'd be like
well that person said I'm ugly or that
person said I'm a [ __ ] or that person
said this and he would just say who
cares so and what like it doesn't change
anything in your day-to-day life it's
just an opinion and
their opinions don't affect your real
day-to-day life and the Internet isn't
real and it's kind of like a mentality
that he's told me
the people on the internet aren't it's
kind of a weird way to look at it but
they're not real in the fact that day to
day in person how many people do you
really talk to do you really deal with
it's not many and I think this and the
internet gives us like a false illusion
of how many people we talk to on a daily
basis
uh seven always give people the benefit
of the doubt so
I am not perfect with this one there's
times where I I haven't followed this
but for the most part
when someone does you wrong
I found
as a woman oh my God sometimes I don't
do this but I really try when someone
does something that I find offensive or
that hurts my feelings I'll say
why and ask the question instead of
getting mad like ask them why they did
that because a lot of times we take
things to be personal and to be about us
but it's really not about us it's about
something with them like they're most
people don't think about anyone else but
themselves
um
and they're not really thinking about
you and so a lot of times we take stuff
personally when it's not about us I'm
trying to think of an example like so
I had a friend it was really frustrating
because she's always late to things she
was always always late late to
everything and just I would want to hang
out with her and she would just never
show up on time and I thought it was
disrespectful and what I realized is
she's late to everyone she's just a late
person and that's her thing she's just
late and I can take it personally and
get mad and say you disrespect me
but you know she just that's just how
she is the other thing is that a lot of
people will be like oh you didn't collab
with me or you didn't do something with
me on the come up so I won't help you
now blah blah blah and it's just like
why would they help you in the comic
it's not about you you just aren't worth
their time why would I hold that against
someone who denied me a collab on the
come up when
I can just collab with them now who
cares but a lot of times like
as people we let our ego get in the way
of things and
yeah and I've just found in life that
things are easier if you give people the
benefit of the doubt and assume they
have good intentions they might not and
sometimes you will get abused and
sometimes that's really frustrating
because you feel like you're a doormat
but in the end of the day like night
kind people win and
you can't go through life like all the
rich people I know are actually very
kind people they they don't make it
through life [ __ ] everyone over maybe
not billionaires I can't tell you how to
be a billionaire but
yeah okay
um
eight my parent my mom always told me
it's better to ask forgiveness than
permission so we would go on vacation
and stuff and we wouldn't necessarily
know the rules of certain things
and my mom would say you know what
instead of asking for permission ask for
forgiveness
and
I had the same attitude when it came to
asking people to do collabs asking
people to come on my show asking for
this this and this and it's like you may
be allowed you might not be allowed but
you can just say sorry later
unless the cops get called I mean
there's a line but you guys get the idea
anyways
um nine my dad he told me always look
forward never look back because you
can't change the past and so there's no
point and as women we I have a hard time
with this too sometimes but as women
this is something we have to get better
at like if you're with someone and they
they [ __ ] up before
it's better to just make nice with them
and move forward and just forget about
it and it's the same thing with any
relationship and you have to remember
like there's times where you [ __ ] up and
you hurt people's feelings and
you know they've probably overlooked it
for you at some point too and you just
didn't even notice and
there's no point in harboring anger and
like looking at the past like always
look forward and it's the same thing
with business decisions and money like
you can't help it if you wait like I
used to count like the money I wasted on
stupid things for like I I wasted money
on an employee that didn't work out and
I paid him for all this work that sucked
and I could have thought hmm wow like
I'm so mad but it's like okay I already
wasted the money it's already gone I
can't do anything about it so look for
what what do we do next and my parents
have lost so much money that they almost
lost their house they bought a
neighborhood right before the market
crashed and
you know they could have said that was a
stupid idea and blah blah blah but it's
like okay
the market crashed they already broke at
the time and
like what are they gonna do now all they
could do is try to fix it
um ten you can't buy creativity so if
you're creative
value that because you think people
can't buy that and they can't out
creative you
yeah okay 11. no grudge is worth it keep
your friends close and keep your enemies
closer try to make nice even with people
even if you don't get along because
yeah keep your friends close keep your
enemies closer
um
no grudge is really worth it a lot of
times it's about ego and it's about oh I
don't want to look stupid but
a lot like my dad told me a story where
there was someone that he lost like a
million dollars to or something like
this guy kind of screwed him over in
some way something happened I don't
really know what
my dad told me he said
you know I could have gotten really mad
at him and never talked to him again but
he actually helped me later with
something because I didn't freak out and
I could have gotten emotional yelled at
him whatever but it's more like
you know how they are keep a note of it
don't get mad just move on and keep a
note of it deal with them less whatever
but no grudge is worth it and a lot of
times when I've had times where I've
gotten angry or had an emotional
reaction to something
I always regret it later
because it's like what was the point it
was just an ego thing you just needed to
say how you felt
um 12 you can always be get another job
so a lot of people are afraid to quit
their job to follow their passions but
you can always get another job
and it's not I was afraid to quit my cup
freaking copy your sales job
that I hated I did that for two years
two years of hell and I it why you guys
get another job you can always go back
and beg you never know
and 13 always wish people well
um
kind of the same thing my dad was saying
before
um
having resentment in your heart is never
good and my my ex had had
an ax that
I resented a little bit at for a time
and my dad always just told me no wish
him well literally hope him hope the for
the best for him it does not help you in
life to have someone do bad after you
wish them well and it stuck with me
because
it's really freeing honestly to wish
someone well and genuinely want them the
best for them and when you say oh I hope
they I hope the bad stuff happens and
it's hard I don't always do this as a
woman sometimes I don't but I try to I
try to give that disclaimer that I try
my best to follow this advice sometimes
I do sometimes I don't but
yeah that that's how many pieces of
advice that's 13 pieces of advice that
my parents taught me
um let me know in the comments what you
want to know in a coffee thought next
I'm kind of just feeling like doing a
lot of coffee thoughts tonight so if you
guys have any videos you want from me
let me know like the video leave a
comment subscribe to the channel bye